There's nothing more I can do
to prepare for this.
Then let's go for it.
(heavy sigh) Okay.
Not convinced by
how shaky my hand is.
If all goes well,
in a few hours' time,
I am going to be tattooing someone.
This is Tash and Gaia.
I'm Tash, Gaia.
We're from Lost Fox Tattoo.
And we're gonna be training Tom
for the next few hours.
Do I need to say,
"Don't try this at home"?
Because not only is it unsafe to do this
without all the facilities we've got here,
we had to go through legal, and insurance,
and permitting stuff, to do this.
If you don't have that support,
do not try this.
As for who I'm tattooing...
This is Han.
Hi!
You might recognise her from
the background of a couple of videos.
Han is on the production team
for this channel.
Yes, and this video was
entirely my idea!
I've got a few tattoos already,
and I just thought it would be fun
to see if Tom can give me one as well.
So, just to be clear,
don't do this.
And if any of us aren't comfortable
at any point here,
we won't be doing this.
With all that in mind,
should we try it?
Yeah.
So, hands washed.
I assume everything else here
is going to be sanitised first.
Yes.    Yes.
Alright.
So, gloves on.
Gloves on.
Gloves on first. You've got yours down there.
So...
I'm going obviously from zero to
hopefully tattooing in one day.
How long would this normally take?
Depends on how brave
your friends are.
That's— Right.
You've got lots of willing friends
from early on that are like,
"You know what?
Yeah cool, you can give me one."
'Cause the sooner you start
on real skin...
...it kind of accelerates it.
So the quicker you get to
actual human skin, the better.
That sounds really weird
when I put it like that.
When you stop, like, tattooing
the neighbourhood cats,
and you start tattooing humans,
(laughter)
that's when you start getting
really, really good, really fast.
And this is synthetic skin then?
Yeah.
Yeah, it feels really weird.
Oh yeah, that's...
It's weirdly skin-like, yeah.
(giggles)
If you look closely,
it should have kind of pores,
almost like real skin.
There's still a very big difference,
because it doesn't stretch in the
same way that real skin stretches.
Right.
But it's a good place to start.
Okay.
Mhm.
This is the machine.
It's a...
Huh.
Like I said, it's a rotary machine,
so it's just got a little motor inside.
So this doesn't
look like your standard...
No, I was—
...what you'd expect.
I had a picture in my head of
what a tattoo gun looked like,
and that is not it.
Yeah, this one is very streamlined.
This is called a pen style.
So you literally just hold it like a pen.
Hold it like a pen.
It's a far cry
from the sailor coils
that you used to have to
wind up with pound coins.
For some reason, that scares me
a little bit more, because like,
"Oh, this is not a different thing."
I feel like I'm gonna be overconfident
if it's just like, "Hold it like a pen."
Yeah, it's just a glorified pencil.
You'll be fine!
(giggles)
(chuckles)
So now, we're just wrapping the part
that you hold with some grip tape.
This is just to help you grip it.
And it also just secures everything.
You are holding something
that is shaking,
Yeah, it's a motor with an offset needle in there.
and you're trying to do a very straight line.
So the grip tape sort of helps...
...swallow some of that vibration.
Alright. (chuckles)
Can I hold that?
You can.
My gloves are still safe, so...
So I've just kinda gone into
my normal pen hold there.
Is that right?
How do I need to hold this?
The way that I usually
hold the machine
would be more like...
...kind of, you got a tighter grip on it
than you would a pen.
Okay.
And... making sure that you've got
a lot of... coverage on it,
rather than just holding it
like a pencil like this.
When you're writing, a lot of
what you do comes from your wrist.
But when you're tattooing,
it comes more from your elbow.
Okay!
Because it keeps it straighter.
Then I think the—
So if you hold it like a pencil,
the temptation is always there
to like, (swishing)
Like this.
Oh yeah.
But when you're pushing,
it's better to have it like...
So if I have two fingers there and
a knuckle wrapped in there, is that...?
Yeah, I mean it's...
There's no hard-and-fast
rule, is there?
It is what feels—
makes you feel more confident.
More in control of everything.
In control.
Alright.
Exactly, exactly.
If you'll give the whole bed
a good spray.
Alright.
Oh, I just got a massive
static shock off that!
Yeah, that happens.
(both laugh)
Obviously, a lot of tattoo artists
will work freehand, but...
...presumably you can
print out a design and then...
...follow the lines along
for someone like myself?
Oh, it's actually pretty rare
that you would freehand.
I'd say in 99 percent of instances,
you would use a stencil.
Okay.
It'll be designs that you've
kind of drawn up beforehand,
And then people
will pick that design,
and then you'll just have it
printed out and ready to go.
Okay. So we've got
everything cling-filmed.
Yeah.
We've got the soap, towels,
tattoo machine, ink...
anything we're missing?
Nope, this is all you'll need.
Alright, and a needle presumably.
And you need a cartridge.
(giggles) You need a needle!
Needle in the cartridge.
That would help.
Alright.
And so...
I'm already nervous,
and this is artificial, fake skin!
This is just plastic.
As soon as you do it, you'll realise,
Okay, okay.
"Okay, this is all right, I've got this."
We'll take them out of the casing
in a minute and have a look.
We can push the needle out
and see all the individual needles inside.
'Cause right now, that just
looks like one thick needle.
Yeah.
So now, if you have a look,
we'll just push the needle up.
And you can see...
Oh!
I mean, I can't—
I can just see,
at the very top, just a little—
looks almost like it's a serrated edge
or something like that.
Yeah. Yeah.
So that's the individual needles.
It has just kind of
sunk in for me...
...that this is like an actual...
...effectively a
medical treatment device.
Like, this is—
This is a really serious thing,
that if all goes well, I am going to be
piercing someone's skin with
in a few hours,
and that has just hit me!
(others laughing)
That's just arrived in my head!
Are you— Are you ready?
Yeah.
(giggling)
Yeah, sure, sure, okay.
So, grabbing the machine.
So, pick up, make sure—
Get in a decent grip.
Make sure I point it... that way,
so I'm facing— yeah, so I can see the needle.
It's coming out that way.
Yeah.
And it's gonna be over here.
And I'm just gonna try
and draw a line...
...that way.
So you wanna dip into the ink
just a little bit.
Okay.
And you'll see it shoot up into the cartridge.
Oh, yeah. That just fills the cartridge.
See?
Again, I don't know if that'll have
shown up on camera,
but it, like, bloomed up.
Yeah.
So that's now
loaded and ready to go?
Yeah, so you wanna just give it
a gentle wipe on the paper you've got.
So that's just getting rid of
a little bit of excess.
That's suddenly terrifying. Okay.
(snickering)
So then you wanna grab
a little bit of the Vaseline,
put it down onto the skin
with your little finger I'd say.
Yep. I just need to
keep that away from me.
Yep.
So how deep?
You wanna make contact, and then
you wanna go maybe a millimetre.
Okay.
Lower than that.
Wow. That...
I expected more resistance.
Mm...
I expected much more
resistance to that.
"Ow."
That... That felt like
it was too deep.
I— I felt, like, resistance off that.
Was it the noise?
Yeah.
Sometimes the noise can be
a bit... scary at first.
But I don't actually think that
that did look very deep.
You might be moving
a bit too fast.
I also think the reason it's making that noise
is because you're not stretching it enough.
So what's happening is it's just
vibrating with the machine.
Okay.
And you're also going very fast.
Okay!
So it's sort of bouncing along,
because you're pulling so fast,
and the needle's, "b-b-b-b-b-boom".
Okay.
Like this, yeah.
Wow, that was really good!
Really? (chuckles)
Yeah! (giggles)
That was really, really good,
wasn't it?
That felt... right.
I don't know why.
Well...
A lot of tattooing is just feeling.
You can feel when it's wrong.
You can feel when it's right.
That's brilliant!
That's really good.
Do you want a job?
(group laughter)
I mean, it's not a straight line.
But... it's a solid line.
Yeah.
And also, you aren't a printer.
You can't draw a perfectly straight line.
It's not possible.
But that's a very straight line.
It's really rare when I do
one of these things, it turns out I...
I'm not immediately terrible.
I'm not used to this!
(laughing)
If you go too light,
you can go over it again
if you're really precise, right?
Yep.
What happens if you go
too deep?
So if you go too deep,
there's less that can be done,
because you can end up
with a blowout.
A blowout is when too much ink
enters in the same place,
and doesn't have anywhere to go,
so it spreads.
So yeah, lighter is
better than too deep.
Can I try doing a curve?
Yeah.
I'll try doing a sine wave
along there, or something.
Yeah, so with curves,
you do actually wanna utilise the wrist.
It helps to kind of plant down,
and then you can use the wrist
to create a natural curve that doesn't waver.
Because if you don't have anything
kind of planting you down,
then you are more likely to wobble
as you go around.
I guess I've just gotta spend
a long time making a lot of lines.
Yep.
♪ (bluesy dubstep-rock)
That is not a circle!
(music ends)
You're doing it without a stencil.
I am.
So let's talk about stencils.
How does that work?
So it's literally just... we print it
straight from our iPads to the printer.
So anything that you've drawn on there
will come out with stencil ink.
You transfer it onto the skin,
and it'll just kinda stick-on transfer,
and you can just trace over it.
Right.
And so these are some stencils
that I've printed out for you.
So I'm not tattooing that ink in.
I'm still using the same ink,
same needle, same everything.
This is just a guide,
and that's just...
Yeah, it's—
...safe to use.
Yeah, it's a guide, and it's
specially formulated for this exact purpose,
and this exact purpose only.
Alright.
Obviously this is
backwards at the minute,
because when you cut them out,
you're gonna put them on this way.
And heads up as well,
it's gonna be way harder to do that...
Okay. Alright.
...than it will to do normal skin.
Let's start with—
Let's start at the top left.
Let's start with the name. Why not?
Yeah? Cool.
It's got some straight lines.
It's got a very
not-straight line in there.
So, on the skin.
Mhm.
So first, we spray some alcohol.
Alright.
And I'm gonna put this up top here,
so I can stretch the skin properly.
And this is the part where you
would shave the skin as well, but...
It's not really necessary here, yep.
Seems a bit superfluous in this instance.
So you just want
one little spray of that.
From about there?
Mhm.    Yeah.
Just rubbing it in until it
starts to feel a little bit sticky.
So then you just wanna place that on,
making sure not to move it around
as soon as it's touched the skin.
It needs to be exactly the right place.
Mhm.
Got it.
Yeah.
Okay.
And then you're gonna wanna
peel it off.
Uh-oop. Little bit leaky there.
Yeah, it's really hard on fake skin.
That would've come out
perfectly on normal skin.
Alright.
And...
Oh, that was wobbly.
I know exactly why
it was wobbly.
I saw you lift your elbow.
Right.
Let's try the O.
Ah, that was awesome.
That felt so much better.
That was so good, wasn't it?
With a guide to go,
that was so much better.
It's not— I tucked in a bit there,
That was really good.
and I shouldn't have done, but...
That was inspired.
...that felt a lot better.
I should've refilled with ink
before doing that,
and I started too far
to the right.
I mean it does look a little bit
like a serial killer
writing their name at this point.
I'll take it, but it's not the...
It's not the straight lines
I had right at the start.
But, practice.
(giggling, inaudible crosstalk)
You okay there?
Yeah, the serial killer line really killed me.
(giggling)
(tittering along)
"Did a serial killer write this name?"
Am I wrong?!
Not entirely(!)
By the looks of it, you're feeling
a little bit more comfortable with those?
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, I mean—
The straight line's solid.
It's matching it,
and it's stopping at that point,
so it doesn't look like
someone's scratching away!
Getting that— Yeah.
The curve on that T looks amazing.
So I think, you know, little flower
with... some petals and...
Are you sure about this?
One hundred percent sure.
Okay.
I wouldn't be doing this if I wasn't—
So I've actually already got
something a little bit similar
to what you're gonna do,
that Tash has already done for me.
This is Benny. He's my raccoon.
(chuckles)
And he's got a little flower
in his mouth.
So we thought we would replicate that.
Alright.
So...
We should just make clear,
this is tattoo, like,
very very basics, 101,
simplest thing there is.
Yeah.
I'm learning the very first step.
Don't try this!
(tittering)
Do not.
I'm absolutely comfortable where we're at,
seeing what you've done here,
and knowing that you'll be
doing this exact stencil
over and over and over again.
Yeah, I feel very much
comfortable, very happy.
Alright, so I'm just gonna drill this
over and over again.
Same pattern, get it in my head.
Mhm. Yep.
♪ (upbeat indie rock)
I don't know why
I looked directly at you.
I realise how dorky this looks,
but I'm not gonna take
any risks with this!
Let's put some more stencils down.
Hey, that's not bad actually.
(music ends)
Those all felt good.
They looked good.
I mean, it's the last one here.
I know we can just put
another sheet down!
(laughs) Something symbolic about that.
But that felt good.
I'm just gonna turn the...
...turn the tattoo machine off.
I mean, of course I'm gonna be critical of it,
'cause I'm critical of everything like that.
I can point out
a dozen things wrong with that.
But we've come a long way from
that wonky one just there.
Yeah!
Han, how are you feeling?
I think it looks great.
Like genuinely, and you know,
this is going on my skin permanently.
And so... you know...
I've got fun tattoos.
I've got silly tattoos.
But I wouldn't put
something on my skin
that I thought in however long,
I was gonna go,
"That looks like trash."
That last one you did,
that looks fantastic.
It looks really, really, really good.
It's not gonna be perfect.
Yeah, but if you look at some of them,
like this one...
That one was lovely.
That was like the second one I did!
I know, it's amazing.
But in all of them, there are
bits of it where you go,
"That's remarkably good."
There are bits that maybe
Yeah.
you might wanna do
a little bit of touching up on.
Yeah.
But as a whole, like, yeah.
Okay well, you stay and
practice all of these,
and we can just
set up a separate bed.
And no pressure.
Alright.
♪ (upbeat hard rock)
(music fades)
After hours and many
little drawings of flowers...
What do you think?
Can I do this safely?
Yes. I think that you have nailed
the health and safety.
And you're really nailing it.
You've really taken it all in.
So Han, I am confident that
I can do this without hurting you.
Yes.
Well... beyond the extent
that tattoos do.
"Harming you."    Okay.
Harming me.
The thing is,
each of these lines...
I've got maybe a 70, 80 percent hit rate
on each of these lines.
The trouble is,
the design requires eight lines.
The odds of me getting
all of these spot-on,
the first time I'm doing it
on actual skin...
It's not 100 percent at all.
And the fact that
in all of these designs,
there doesn't ever seem to be
something that's not fixable.
This was one I was gonna ask
you two about.
Like, how would you fix these?
Could you fix these?
Can you fix this?
All of these are definitely in a fixable state.
Yeah.
Okay.
Obviously we're gonna be here,
we're gonna be watching,
and if there is anything that you're not
comfortable or confident to touch up,
we can do that for sure.
Alright.
I'm happy, and I've already
set you up a station over there.
It's all correctly set up,
sanitised, ready to go.
So we're just gonna move you
from this bed to that bed.
Alright.
(chuckles)
Let's go!
I'm glad you said it, not me.
So, the first thing we do is...
Disinfect me.
...disinfect.
Thank you.
I've got surgical assistance here.
Thank you folks.
Alright, so that's...
...disinfected.
And then...
...razor?
Yeah.
You okay with that?
Yep.
Think we've covered that.
I've got pretty smooth arms.
But that's, yeah, looks pretty good.
Alright.
Spray of the Stencil-Prep...
...which gets rubbed in.
You're gonna have to
remind me of all the steps
as we go through this, you really are.
You're doing really well.
These are all the steps so far.
I'm-a place it just here then.
Yeah, and then hold it on
nice and tight.
Make sure there's contact
for all of the design, yep.
(sharp inhale)
That's the cleanest stencil
we've had yet!
Okay!
And it looks really cute. Thank you.
I'll hand that over to you there.
Alright so, one more time.
Are you 100 percent okay
with that being there?
Yes. I'll do what you always do
when you go and get a tattoo,
which is you go stand,
have a look in the mirror,
Okay.
and just go,
Take it for a test drive.
"Yeah, yeah, I think that suits me."
Take it for a spin around the block.
So I'll pop over to the mirror over here.
Yeah.
I think it looks very cute!
Okay.
I think it's very cute there.
And I'm just gonna be clear,
that's been printed on an inkjet printer.
That looks perfect.
Yep.
I'm sure I can do this safely.
You guys are sure I can do this safely.
Mhm.
It's not gonna look like that.
It's not— (laughs)
I'm gonna do the
very, very best I can.
I have no doubt that you will.
Alright.
So yeah.
I'm very happy, so, you know.
Let's do it.
Yeah? ♪ Cool ♪
So if I'm here...
How's that?
Yeah.
(sigh)
The sk—
A tattoo feels
so much more surgical
when you have
three people around you!
It really feels like you're about go into surgery.
"Are you all right?"
"Shh, count backwards from ten."
(laughing) Exactly!
"Think happy thoughts."
I mean, the thing for me is realising
— and this is obvious in hindsight —
your skin is curved.
Yes.
(heavy puffing)
♪ (tense music)
Okay.
Yeah?
So I'm gonna just—
So, stretch the skin like that.
I mean...
...what more can I rehearse?
It's go time.
It's go time, baby.
Yep.
Yeah.
Bonza.
You got this.
(snickering)
In an entirely unironic way,
like, you got this.
It's gonna be great.
Okay, so.
First thing, Vaseline over
the whole area.
Yeah.
Mhm.
About that much?
A little bit less, yeah.
So we're just gonna go...
like that.
See how it doesn't smudge
as much on the skin.
It doesn't smudge anything,
and that's just visible.
Okay.
Mhm.
So we're stretching the skin there,
we're stretching the skin there,
and I'm following...
This is probably a bad time
to say my hand's shaking.
It's okay.
The way frequencies work,
when the thing's shaking,
they'll cancel each other out
and it'll be perfectly smooth.
Science.
Alright. There's nothing more
I can do to prepare for this.
Then let's go for it.
Alright so, we're gonna
fill up the ink.
Yep.
That's filled.
That look okay to you?
Yep, just wipe— Exactly.
Just wipe.
Mhm.
And have at the
forefront of your mind,
you want to hover, not sink in.
You want to go slow.
And you want to look at
where you're going.
(sigh) I'm not convinced at
how shaky my hand is.
Okay.
(heavy breath)
(sting ending)
(shaky breathing, sighing)
How was that?
♪ Sick! ♪
Well done!
There's more wobble than I'd like.
It's all right!
But that was not...
That's— That's—
I can see where my hand shook.
Mhm.
But we got a line.
I'd say dab that now
to get rid of any excess.
It's not gonna wipe the stencil away.
Yeah.
From my point of view, that felt like
every other tattoo I've ever had.
Mhm.
That—
That wasn't more painful.
Alright. Alright.
It's not... perfectly
inkjet printer smooth.
(chortles)
But it is on the line.
I'd be a bit freaked out
if it was.
It's on the line.
You're not an inkjet printer.
Yes.
You're in the wrong career if it is.
Yeah, I'm also not running out
of ink halfway through
and claiming— Anyway.
Oh Tom, that was brilliant!
That felt good.
That was so good!
That felt good!
That was really good— Sorry.
Gonna wipe it.
(giggles)
That was wonderful.
I'm not looking at it til the end.
That's a solid line!
I said it was about, like,
80 percent chance on each line.
(laughing)
(chef kiss)
So far we've got a
three out of five. We've got—
I think that's about the best you're
gonna get here. I'm happy with that.
I can't wait. I'm so excited.
Let's try the other side.
Okay, don't get overconfident.
Calm, same pace,
same depth, same everything.
Yeah.
Do I want to change my angle on this?
And follow...
That felt a little fast at the start.
That was a bit fast.
Have a little wipe
and see how it went in.
Not bad.
It's a little patchy at the very start.
I think I'd leave it that way
for a professional,
That's absolutely fine, yeah.
rather than try a second line on that.
Now the petals.
Alright.
Five lines left.
And a little squiggle in the middle.
Colour in the centre.
You just have—
You don't want to forget that little squiggle.
Alright, here we go.
Mhm?
Not sure on that one. We'll see.
Little bit light on the start.
Little bit light. Let me just...
It's all there though.
Mhm.
It's all there.
So that is slightly smaller
than the petal design.
So I'm gonna try to make sure that
if I'm gonna make an error,
it's gonna be the same
kind of small error.
Mhm.
The same kind of—
The same way,
you know what I mean?
It was okay.
Mhm.
Stretch the skin.
That speed was much better.
I'm gonna go for the next one,
'cause I'm set up for it.
Alright, number four.
Yeah, happy.
No.
Sorry, Han.
I missed on some of that.
It's okay.
I just flat out—
I was not deep enough, and your skin
was moving away, and I didn't realise it.
So, I'm gonna wipe that.
That's okay.
and I'm gonna see if that's
a thing I can patch up
or whether give it to you.
Yeah. Yeah, happy for you
to try patching it up.
If you know exactly, you know...
Oh yeah, you've got that.
That was a clear—
That was like a total miss.
That was just a total miss.
So you can—
Yeah, I just forgot that
skin is three-dimensional.
That was on me.
I'm gonna sweep
this way around on this.
Mhm.
Excellent.
(sigh) I'm not sure—
I think I still missed that last part.
That's okay, 'cause that's where
you're gonna put the dot, in the middle.
So that's all right.
That's now a
continuous line. Alright.
Okay. Last line.
Woo-hoo!
Last petal, and then the dot.
Let's go!
Agh! Sorry, Han.
It's good— It's not a disaster.
But again, the skin's three-dimensional.
It got away from me.
Alright.
It's okay.
Let's wipe that.
We started so well!
So I just need to...
That felt better. That felt better.
That was excellent!
That was a really good touchup.
Okay. So the last bit
is the very centre.
Mhm.
And I just need to, small circle.
Yip.
I think... I think that's it.
I think that's it!
(anxious shiver)
You know what?
I think that might be the best one
of the flowers that I've done.
Yay!
It's not perfect, not by a long way!
There's a little bit of wobble
here and there...
...but there's nothing in there
that I know you can't fix!
Yeah!
Han, do you wanna have
a quick look? There's the mirror...
I'm really excited.
(gasp) That looks so good!
♪ (emotional acoustic music)
Like, genuinely so good!
(chuckles)
Yeah, and they're...
Some of the lines are a bit squiggly.
But as a whole...
...that one whole-ass tattoo!
Thank you, Han!
It genuinely looks so cute.
I'm very, very chuffed.
Look at that!
(chuckling)
(exhausted laughing)
Well done! You did good!
(group cheering)
That looks so good.
You know what? Now I'm not
close-up to it, yeah it does.
Thank you, Han.
Oh, you did so good!
Little bit closer to me.
I love it. Truly.
It's two weeks later.
We are filming something else, and...
thought you might want a quick update.
How's it doing, Han?
It is completely healed.
And it is looking as good
as it did when you did it.
I think that's often a good tell, is...
Do bits kind of fade
or peel off when it's healing?
Oh, no. It looks fantastic!
Thank you!
That's such a relief.
Thank you, Han.
[Caption+ by JS*
caption.plus | @caption_plus]